منعت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بقنابل
الصوت والغاز المسيل للدموع مسيره شارك
فيها عشرات من نشاطاء السلام والحقوقيين
الاجانب الى جانب ناشطين فلسطينيين نظمت
للتضامن او نظمت للتضامن مع سكان بلده
حواره والقرى المحيطه بها جراء اعتداء
المستوطنين عليهم وعلى منازلهم وممتلكاتهم
كما اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال عددا من
المشاركين فيها
ومنعتهم من الوصول الى بلده حوارا انطلقت
المسيره من مفترق حاج الزعتر العسكري
جنوبي نابلس وتوجهت الى بلده حواره لكن
قوات الاحتلال اعترضت المسيره ومنع
التقدمها نحو البلده
ينضم الينا من بلده حواره جنوب نابلس
مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شمال اهلا بك معنا
في ظل
ادانا واضحه من هذا الوفد من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لجرائم المستوطنين التي ارتكبت
في بلده حواره لكن الاجراءات ضد
الفلسطينيين من قبل قوات الجيش الاحتلال
لا زالت مستمر
نعم بكل تاكيد الجيش الاسرائيلي على مدار
الساعه ومنذ سته ايام تحديدا قد كثف من
تواجده في شارع حواره في جنوبي مدينه
نابلس الذي خلفي مباشره وهذا الشارع الذي
يستخدمه المستوطنون والفلسطينيون على حد
سواء على مدار الساعه الجيش الايطاليه
دائما يكون هناك نقاط وسكنات عسكريه
اسرائيليه وايضا دوريات للجيش الايطالي
بشكل مستمر وعلى مدار الساعه في هذا
الشارع ولكن في الايام السته الاخيره ومنذ
يوم الاحد الماضي هناك تكثيف للتواجد
العسكري الاسرائيلي والاجراءات العسكريه
التي ايضا نقصت حياه الفلسطينيين في هذه
البلده ومنعت اصحاب المحل التجاريه من
فتحها على مدار الايام الماضيه وايضا ذلك
بذلك بذرائع امنيه حسب جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه ايضا المستوطنون بين الحين
والاخر هناك يحاولون ايقاف سياراتهم في
واستفزاز المواطنين الفلسطينيين كما جرى
اثناء جوله الوفد الاوروبيه والبعث
الاوروبيه التي كانت تنظم جوله ميدانيه في
قريه زعتر وبلده حواره حيث كان هناك
المسؤولون الاوروبيون يحاولون تنظيم
القاء بيان حول هذه الزياره ولكن اعترضهم
احد المستوطنين وهو عضو كنيسه في الجانب
الاسرائيلي
رفع لافتات للقتله المستوطنين وحاول تشويش
هذه الزياره من خلال اعتراضهم بهذا الشكل
وقد اضطر الوفد الاوروبيه لمغادره بلده
حوار بعدها ان القى بيان ادانا فيه هذه
الاعمال من خلال من قبل المستوطنين وايضا
اجراءات الجيش الاحتلال وايضا طالب الجيش
الاحتلال كقوه قائمه بالاحتلال في الارض
على الارض الفلسطينيه ان يؤمن الحمايه
للفلسطنين من جرائم الاعتداء المستوطنين
وبالتالي هناك ايضا على الشهادات التي
تلقاها الوفد الاوروبي خلال هذه الزياره
من خلال زيارته لبيت الشهيد سامح لقطه
الذي كان يحاول الدفاع عن بيته والذوده عن
اطفاله واولاده خلال اعتداء المستوطنين
وايضا عند عند زيارته هذا الوفد لعدد من
المنازل التي تعرضت للاحتراق له الحرق
الكامل والجزء والاستماع الى شهادات
المواطنين الذين اكدوا بان المستوطنون ان
المستوطنين دائما يحاولون الاستفزاز
والاعتداء عليهم وبالتالي الوافد الاوروبي
والدبلوماسيون وايضا الممثلين المؤسسات
الحقوقيه والاسرائيليه قد اذانوا هذه
الاعمال التي ينفذها المستوطنون وايضا
اجراءات الاحتلال على الارض وذلك بحمايه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وايضا اقترب
بمحاسبه كل من له يد في هذه الاعتداءات
وهذه الجرائمه التي وصفت بالمشاهد المروعه
التي شاهدوها خلال هذه الزياره من خلال
الاحراق اكثر من اربعين منزلا جزئي وكلي
وايضا احراق المئات من المركبات
الفلسطينيين خلال الاعتداء الذي وقع يوم
الاحد الماضي واستمرا على مدار يومين من
خلال هذه الاعتداءات وهذه الانتهاكات من
قبل المستوطنين وطالب ايضا بتوفير الحمايه
الدوليه للمدنين باسرع وقت ممكن
والمحاسبه المسؤولين عن كل هذه الجرائم
سواء من المستوطنين او اجراءات او
الاسرائيليين الجنود الذين يحمون
المستوطنون عندما يقومون بعمليات اعتداءات
على الفلسطينيين من بلده حوار جنوب نابلس
الجزيره سمير ابو شمال شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه الاضاحات